any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
welcome everybody to this edition of the
into the impossible podcast i am your
fearful host
brian keating and today it is a great
pleasure a treat in fact
for me to welcome none other than kamran
vaffa of harvard university how are you
cameron
thank you very much brian for having me
your program it's a
great pleasure i'm fine and looking
forward to our discussions
yes i've been uh just devouring your
book which we're going to talk a lot
about today puzzles to unravel
the universe and i've been fascinated
with puzzles
my whole life mostly my inability to
solve them
but you are noted for having made
tremendous contributions to the world of
theoretical physics
and this is your first popular science
book as i understand
it and i always like to say there's a
piece of advice that you never should
judge a book by its cover
but on this on this book not only do you
have
a very mysterious and and puzzling
imagery
uh but you also have endorsements in
comia from none other than edward
whitton
who i've tried to get on the show
unsuccessfully but i'll talk to you
about that later
uh and also uh brian greene another
brian
actually my kids favorite brian in
astrophysics
but i want to ask you how did you come
up with the name of the book
puzzles to unravel the universe and how
did you come up with the
artwork that so beautifully graces the
cover of this book
well the the title i think was motivated
by a course i'm teaching
uh for harvard freshman called physics
math and puzzles
it's a freshman seminar and uh so the
book was
basically it was grown out of this
course
and so i decided i was thinking about
what title to choose if i had
chosen physics math and puzzles it
sounded a little bit
um maybe boring so i thought maybe i
should use some elements of it without
sounding too
academic and a bit more kind of exciting
in terms of applications to the real
world and so on so i thought that
which which involves actually the
motivation behind the whole course which
is the connections with the real world
so i thought
unraveling the universe through puzzles
puzzles to unravel the universe does
justice to what i wanted to convey
and that's why i chose that
as far as the recover i got some help
from some some people
online but this whole design and all
that happened during the pandemic
so i decided uh during the pandemic one
thing i could do
is to finish this series of notes into a
book which i
decided to do and self-publish it just
to go over
to get it quickly out and get it done so
that is people who may want to be
looking at it
could have a chance to do it during the
pandemic as well so
so it was done in a bit of a speedy way
at the end but um
so that's that's what it is but i'm very
happy with the with the
the cover of the book as well as the way
the book came out
yes it's very intriguing and it matches
the subject matter as well
uh i want to make a distinction between
mysteries and
puzzles and wonder if you do that as
well uh
to me there's a difference between a
mystery and a puzzle and i once
discussed this with
freeman dyson who i know you knew the
late great freeman dyson and it was that
you know a puzzle is something that
could be solved
maybe i can't solve it because i'm not
as smart as you but a mystery
might not be solvable and i wonder do
you make a distinction between
mysteries versus puzzles
well in a sense uh puzzles
aspire to be mysteries and that's the
way good puzzles aspire to be like
mysteries that's not quite solvable but
gives you an inspiration to new ideas so
i view puzzles always like that
but i i think for example in the book i
talk about the enigma of quantum
mechanics
i still view it as a mysterious features
that we encounter even though we think
we understand
quantum mechanics you know the features
of experimentation within quantum
mechanics
are serious still to me and so that in
that sense i agree we haven't solved it
or it
it's not solvable at this point it might
continue to be mysterious or maybe it
gets resolved in a different form
similar things happen like black holes
we have similar enigmas about black hole
and mysteries about black hole
puzzles are pieces which kind of
as i say try to get some features of
these mysteries
in some little nuggets of truth and you
can kind of
wrap your mind around it and kind of
understand it at least so there's kind
of
there's a distinction but there's this
also this relation they want to
reinforce each other that is
you're hoping that the mysteries become
like puzzles that you can solve that's
the way i look at it
yeah i looked at uh puzzles i remember
the most famous one perhaps is uh
rubik's cube is a
as a puzzle that i became infatuated
with as a kid
in the early 1980s i think it's just
about 40 years old or maybe a little bit
older
made by i believe a hungarian named
rubik
and we became fabulously wealthy and his
whole life is wrapped up
in in this particular uh cube and
and it's uh even such to the point that
he
cannot really sleep when he tries to
solve it faster than his previous record
etc there are all these competitions and
he can't really do it as well as other
people could or
when he was a younger man he could solve
it even faster i wonder
you know if you look at your career is
there a particular puzzle or mystery
that you're most fascinated by
among the many things you just mentioned
quantum mechanics black holes
later we'll get into string theory are
there things that just keep you up at
night and that you won't rest until you
solve them or perhaps make some
contribution towards the understanding
of them
[Music]
these projects that i've been involved
with with is have these elements of
mysteries and puzzles mixed together so
uh good problems have interesting
reformulation in terms of things we can
understand clearly in terms of the model
that we are approaching
so there are many examples that what
comes to my mind the computation of the
entropy of the black hole for example
using ideas about
how you count the string theory degrees
of freedom in the
using the geometry of string
compactification the work i did with my
collaborator and the strum manager
is an example but there are many such
things and i don't think
i would just pick one particular ones i
think
even the some of the papers that may not
be as well received or as
well known in general i still might
enjoy some of the puzzles that i can
encounter
and to me it's hard to calibrate it and
organize it in terms of the ranking of
which one is
higher or lower in terms of interest to
me but uh
so even even trivial sounding puzzles
could be interesting and i find
interesting so
so many of the puzzles that i discussed
in the book on the face of it might
sound like
okay so what it's so simple what what
you want to learn but
even those simple ones i i i kind of
think
after even after i've solved it and
discussed it for 10 000 times
i still enjoy thinking about it so i
think it's like
the aftertaste of the puzzle is what uh
what attracts me to to thinking because
it gives you
a springboard for other ideas it gives
you say oh maybe this thing means a bit
more something else and you begin to
think
so it might sound by itself kind of like
a boring statement but the connections
and what what else it might relate to is
what fascinates me
yeah i think it was uh that uh
maybe it was albert michelson one of the
i think he was the first
u.s nobel prize winner one of the first
uh nobel prize winners from america
and he said you know experiments are
like puzzles
to a kid and just like a kid will do a
puzzle even once
he or she has solved it he'll do it
again or she'll do it again
because every time they do it they get a
little taste
of the thrill that they got when they
solved it the first time
i feel like that as a as an
experimentalist i wonder though there
are some puzzles
and mysteries that are known to be
unsolvable i'll say
something like girdle's incompleteness
theorem it's it's known
that mathematics a formal mathematical
system is
uh is you know self-inconsistent in a
sense which is
we know that to be true we don't know
why that's true necessarily
i often find that about experimental
physics as well that experimental
physicists such as myself
have this desire to know what is
scientific what is worth pursuing
and some people don't want to pursue
things like string theory
i want to ask you what do you decide is
worthy of your
limited we all have limited attention
and time how do you know when a mystery
or puzzle is worth solving or
may have it be known that it's
unsolvable how do you divide your time
uh amongst these many activities well i
think that
uh i mean that's part of having
experience with various problems that
we encounter you get a sense of what is
doable and what is not
and that's the difference between
somebody who starts doing science at the
beginning like when i was a student
and now where i have seen many many
problems solved and some of them not
being solved and so on
by seeing this through different uh
through different
kinds of projects and so on you get a
sense of what is doable and what is
practical so
on the one hand you know what is
practical what is google on the other
hand you have a sense of what is
important and interesting so
then you take an overlap between these
ideas here okay among the ones which are
potentially solvable which ones are
potentially more interesting and
impactful and then you kind of
based on that overlap you you decide
what projects to work on so
so that's usually how i go about doing
it so
there could be many interesting
questions that i would love to do it but
i have no idea so therefore i wouldn't
try those but and on the other hand
there are many things like i could do
immediately but they sound like not that
exciting or impactful i won't
waste my time with so so there's kind of
like
the intermediate line where you kind of
try to do the most interesting thing you
can do
and that combination of being able to
uninteresting is what needs to be
both for me to feel like it's a good
project
so i was thinking as i read your book
and thinking back to a conversation i
had with lenny suskin last week
about one of the most impressive
characters
in his mind in history aristarchus and
you mentioned aristarchus as well in the
book
uh towards the end and you talk about
the fact that aristarchus had these
ideas about heliocentrism which we now
know to be
true but could not be proven because it
was impossible to measure for example
the parallax
of of stars at that time in fact it
wasn't
proven the parallax was not proven until
i believe the 1700s even after galileo
and and yet galileo had tools to
actually prove
copernicus uh was right and he didn't
use them instead he used
uh other methods which turned out to be
wrong for example his book the dialogue
was originally going to be titled on the
flux of the tides and
he contended that the tides on earth's
oceans were caused by the
motion of sloshing and revolution and
rotation of the earth
not as we now know from the
gravitational influence of the moon
so he was overwhelmed by the kind of
notion that
copernicus was right so much so that he
used incorrect evidence
to uh to justify and bolster the
hypothesis
uh on the other hand you know uh our
stark has had the right idea and lenny
calls him you know the most
interesting scientist perhaps in history
because he had the right idea but the
technology wasn't sufficient
what do you say to people who say string
theory
or studying the properties of black hole
singularities
which we'll get to in a minute as well
what do you say to those people that say
it's not worth
spending any time on it because you
can't falsify the
singularity you can't falsify string
theory it's
so flexible it predicts or accommodates
way too many
outcomes how do you justify that um
is there an opportunity to appeal to
future technology
uh as in the case of galileo and
aristarchus future
eventually technology caught up and
proved them right do you think the same
thing will happen with string theory and
if not
why should we study it right so as you
say
brian many of the things about string
theory are at the level
of predictions theoretical predictions
that
are very difficult to experimentally
check
with our current level of technology
so so in some sense that promise for the
future
and so the question would be
as you say why should we spend time on
something that we cannot check in our
lifetime
as correct or incorrect and so forth
if there were no method to check our
ideas
then we would have then i would have
abandoned doing string theory for
exactly that reason however due to the
interesting interconnection of different
ideas in high energy theoretical physics
you can actually check ideas
theoretically
so you can check the validity of an idea
from a different perspective
and come to a conclusion whether that
idea is correct or false
without experimentation somewhat of
course
that would validate the idea itself as
being self-consistent
logically correct mathematically
consistent whether or not that's part of
the explanation of our current universe
we still have to wait
but but we have seen so much encouraging
results
from string theory in terms of islamic
consistency in
before relation different pieces of
physics that we have discovered like
strong interaction
what kind of forces are are working
there things about what happens for
uh cosmology what happens for black
holes
we now know there are black holes also
very clearly i mean there's no doubt
about them
and the fact that these high ideas and
string theory come
to get give a self-consistent picture to
many aspects of them makes us believe in
them
and like for example the prediction of
hawking made about black holes the fact
that black holes have
entropy despite the fact that einstein's
equations predicts that they are unique
is taking into account of the quantum
mechanics
the work of beckenstein and hawking in
particular showed that no there must be
some degrees of freedom
which are inside the black hole there
are some microstates and the fact that
string theory was able to account for
those degrees of freedom
at least in specific classes of black
holes is already
surprising and gives us a confidence
that the theory
hangs together now the details about how
it will relate to our universe
then can we understand the electron has
such and such a mass
and so on remains to be seen but even
now
even now i'll give you one example we
can make predictions
right now from string theory which have
experimentally been verified
now these exp these predictions are
rather
in a sense you would say not as precise
a prediction but still
is a prediction and i will give you one
example so for example you take the
electron
and it has a mass and if you compute the
mass of the electron in the fundamental
units of physics
which is uh clank mass it's a very tiny
mass
implying units is something of the order
of 10 to the minus
i don't know 22 or 23. it's a very tiny
number
so we say great do we have any
prediction that the electron mass should
have been this small
without knowing that there is an
electron and just by knowing that there
is
electric charge and by knowing that
there is dark energy in the universe
you find the bound for the electron mass
you find that the electron mass
electron mass has to be bounded by
10 to the minus 1 on the upper edge
and it's above 10 to the minus 31 on the
lower edge
so the the lower bound comes from the
concentration of dark energy
and the upper bound comes from
consideration of what is called the weak
gravity conjecture that
gravity is always the weakest force in
any any consistent universe so
putting these together you find the
range for the mass of the electron and
lo and behold
10 to the minus 23 which is the mass of
the electron
is bigger than 10 to the minus 31 and
smaller than 10 to the minus
so there are some predictions that you
can see not as precise as we would
typically like in physics right i'm not
going to write a grant proposal right
exactly but still the idea that this is
has no falsifiable prediction
is not correct there is there are
predictions that if the electron mass
was somewhere
outside this regime you could have said
okay this is inconsistent
with these ideas so therefore there are
at least something
arising from this i might i might gently
push back and say
you know there are considerations in
your book that you bring up from
what's called naturalness that uh that
that you could actually get the black
hole entropy to within a factor of pi
or so uh just based on dimensional
analysis so
that doesn't require my um you know any
string theoretics at all
and you might also be able to push back
i might
gently again with respect that uh you
know that weinberg made predictions
about the
you know value of dark energy um
independent of the string landscape but
then it was eventually realized to
accommodate that you'd have to have
something like a landscape which we'll
get into in the multiverse
so is it unique to string theory or you
know if my
smart undergraduate can derive it from
her considerations of dimensional
analysis does it really
count as a prediction of string theory
or could it equally be used by
uh fermi to say it's a type of fermi
calculation
okay so good question so let's go back
to the black hole question you raised
first of all
even there it's not clear because
consideration of
dimensional analysis you mentioned
presupposes that we make an assumption
that the entropy of a black hole is
related to the area of the black hole
and naively would absolutely relate to
this volume
and that's not true that was one of the
surprising predictions of hawking so
another dimensional analysis without
giving a totally wrong answer if you
just use the
volume so you have to first assume this
area okay let's assume it's area why
should we get the
factor of one quarter of the area
measured in plank units what should be
one quarter
we don't know a priori from that
calculation hawking's calculation shows
it does
well string prediction not only gives
you that one quarter
but actually gives you an infinite
further correction
instead that's one quarter of area plus
a
coefficient times log of the area plus
another coefficient divided by the area
plus another question infinite expansion
in the area so not only it gives you
hawking's answer it gives you all the
possible corrections to it
so it's not something that hawking did
not calculate so from string theory we
not only get the leading term when the
area is large
but subleading correction when the area
is not huge so these subleading
corrections are
shows you that there's a very clear
picture of how you derive these
statements
and not just the overall coefficient in
front of the area
so it hangs together it is non-trivial
and to me these are the kind of examples
that
uh bolsters our confidence it's string
theory and its validity
and other approaches people have tried
does not give you something as concrete
and as
precise as uh as we have seen in
strength here
so thank you that's uh very uh
masterfully explained
actually uh came away just now with a
new appreciation
of the depth of the mysteriousness of
that particular puzzle so your
unifying mysteries and puzzles for me
cameron uh
to be congratulated um so we talk about
unification and symmetry later because i
want to talk about hacking
uh puzzle solving later on do you solve
do you do crossword puzzles
no i don't okay you know who does a lot
of crossword puzzles marilyn simons
who's uh
the wife of your good friend jim simons
who i believe you've written papers with
uh not too long ago uh we'll get to that
in a little bit but i want to talk about
a conversation i had with lenny
last week lenny suskin your friend and
lenny and i were talking about
singularities and i said to him
uh imagine if you get a note from god
although he doesn't believe in god so
you'll have to take my word for it
i said to him imagine you get a note and
it says that
um actually there uh there are no
singularities at the center of black
holes
uh within the horizon it's just purely
classical and furthermore god gives you
a note
and it says um the universe follows the
kind of cyclical eon hypothesis of uh
sir roger penrose who's been on the show
many times
and or the uh or a bouncing cosmology of
my friend
paul steinhardt and yours at princeton
who's been on the show all so many times
i'll put links to that
and uh and so there are no there's no
singularity needed whatsoever
um why why do we think that quantum
mechanics needs to be
wedded to married to uh gravity
in those two cases to my mind those are
the only cases where
i often hear my fellow friends and
physicists theorists mostly
they say well we have to unite gravity
with quantum mechanics because of
singularities well what if there are no
singularities
would you still say that we need to have
a theory of everything in that way
no i wouldn't my problem with unifying
quantum theory and gravity is far beyond
even if there were no singularities
i would have thought that it would be
saying like could i have electrons which
are quantum but protons which are not
to me it's like that it's not because
there are different forces the gravity
is one of the forces you could say well
how about gauge forces be classical a
quantum but the other one be quantum
there's no formulas in which that makes
sense you cannot talk about what is your
formism are you talking about
how do you describe the physics in that
context it doesn't make sense
now you can treat classical gravity if
you assume the gravity is not dynamical
in other words if
there's no graviton if there's no mold
classically that
propagates but that's not the case we do
know that there are gravitational waves
for example so
gravity is dynamical and we don't know
that there are gravitons but
well there's a there's a classical wave
i mean so there's the fact that the wave
comes there's no doubt so there's
there's something moving
yes so that's what i mean by dynamical
in quantum mechanics we call them made
of gravitons but
regardless there's something moving and
so the question is how do you describe
this moving wave
in terms of classical physics of quantum
physics and so you cannot say okay
if an electron which is quantum
interacts with this classical wave what
does that mean
so that doesn't that that that is that
is a conundrum i don't think
singularities is the reason i believe
gravity has to be described quantum
mechanically however
since you mentioned the synthesizer of
the black hole if
the gravity were just classical then
you might think oh okay this bad and the
singularities are not possible and
therefore this
incomplete the theory and therefore one
way out would be yes quantum mechanics
resolves
a singularity another resolution might
be as you say for example there could be
higher order terms and einstein's theory
which we have ignored and if you put it
back in maybe gets rid of singularity
or something so to me the nature of the
singularity is not a convincing
explanation of the existence of quantum
description of gravity
so um thinking about the other
property that people associate with
black holes uh
actually lenny suggested that to him the
singularity is almost less interesting
than what he calls the stretched horizon
um in some uh in some fashion in his
books
hit the black hole war his battle with
uh stephen hawking to make the world
safe for quantum mechanics
he claims the horizon is much more um
is much more interesting from a quantum
mechanical perspective
what do you make about that is the
horizon of of interest
to quantum uh to those of us who are
trying to unify gravity with quantum
mechanics
in a sense i think i i sympathize with
that view that somehow
universal aspects of black hole seem to
be correlated with the properties of the
horizon
so so somehow a deep understanding of
why and how that quite
how that works seems to be a big piece
of the puzzles for black holes
we know that the nature of the
singularities and the structure of them
changes by little assumptions that you
might make and so that's that's in some
sense unstable kind of a question
but the horizon is robust somehow the
existence of the horizons and the
properties of the horizons and
what do we think about measurability or
imageability of horizon
those are more robust questions so i
agree with with that that viewpoint
and i had uh juan maldasena who's
another friend of yours um
on the show and we talked a lot about um
about wormholes and in fact
humanly traversable wormholes uh i want
to get your
opinion on why do you think uh someone
as bright as juan
who you referenced in the book why would
he spend his time on something
which is you know surely um
inaccessible for for quite some time do
you do you think this is a fruitful use
of his time
well i think he's i think probably you
asked him or you could ask him but i
think that
the ideas of wormhole is just
understanding warholm is to try to
understand what we think about quantum
gravity can do
uh i don't think he's necessarily
thinking about science fiction kind of
wormholes even though he
might even talk about those the
traversable ones
but the idea of studying wormholes i
think
was studied many many many decades ago
but
even more recently in works that there
was for example lenny and juan worked on
connection between einstein rose and
eisan padovsky rosa and paradox and
einstein rose and bridge which is this
wormhole geometry
so the connecting them and so forth
shows that certain things that
might be understanding who's
understanding is
enriches connecting different parts of
physics perhaps motivates one to study
one warhol's more
more uh vigorously um traversability
whether we can send the spaceship there
this and that and so on is
at this point not not in the cars for
our universe we don't see that
under our understanding does not
necessarily lend to that direction
but i think i would not be deterred nor
would i find this more overwhelming
reason to study wormholes i think we
should study them regardless
yeah his response to me on the podcast
was that he
he has found it a fruitful way to
understand quantum mechanics
and and um and gravitational fields so
he views it as fruitful and important um
and yet there are criticisms of the
the work on which that paper is based
upon a series of papers he's written on
wormholes and traversable wormholes
in that they rely on results that are
uh are completely unproven and perhaps
unacceptable
by your colleague and my friend lisa
randle
and her colleague um sundrum which are
these you know
five-dimensional universes or they rely
on
um you know one's a major contribution
these ads
uh cft kind of dualities um
those are things we we don't believe we
live in five dimensions and we don't
believe that we live in
ads if anything it seems more likely
after i read your book
uh that we live in a ds not ads um
so again these these questions of
are they just merely you know i i could
also point to a crossword puzzle or a
rubik's cube and say
they're very challenging you're very
smart if you can solve them my kids can
solve them i can't solve them
i i take apart the rubik's cube it turns
out you can put it back together
take it apart and no one will know that
you did it um although i joked once
uh come run i wonder if you'll you'll
get this joke i said i i got to the
point where i could solve
five sides of the rubik's cube but i
just can't get the sick side
right that's a good one uh but anyway
getting back to this yeah i mean five
dimensional random
syndrome uh you know background space
times uh
ads where we don't live in an ads
universe um
again it just seems like higher order
adding on higher order speculation
when you know i i just i it's hard to
to justify and i'm not saying that only
as an experimentalist there are
theoreticians that
that will say the same thing why don't
they spend their time working on you
know
calculating some cross-sections or or
whatever i i don't know what theorists
do to be honest with you but
um but is it is it not you know um kind
of
speculative to study these things unless
you feel like you're learning about math
and that's important
to learn about five dimensional uh space
time and adscft where do you stand on
that
well let me say instead of that specific
one because
i think let me just change your question
a little bit
uh the questions are why do we spend our
time on theoretical questions which are
not directly relevant to our universe
that's
i think you're giving that through
examples of for example five dimensions
or
anti-deceptive space or this and that so
i will try to
i will try to give you a motivation for
why how how we come about
so what do we know about our universe
well we know it's made of you know
particles electrons
quarks photons this and that and their
forces between them great
what do we know about their forces well
we know quite a bit we know
what is called the standard model
describes the forces between them the
standard model consists of the various
kind of forces the electro weak forces
the strong forces and so on and within
this context we understand how these
particles interact with forces
okay now you come to asking why
why do we have this particle why do we
have this force
can we have other kinds of forces could
we have so this is the
beginning of a question could we have
for example
in our universe instead of having this
finite number of gauge group
billions of gluons or billions of
photons or
why do you have just one little photon
why do you have only one strong force
why don't we have much more
in fact if you were to write a random
theory
in four dimension which is consistent
with quantum field theory with
with finance rules of calculations and
everything you would naively say okay
it would be like a gauge group with you
know billions of gluons and this and
that and this many particles and that
many
but no no no we only see very few
particles with very few
forces around why okay now you might say
well this is metaphysics i have no idea
why i don't care about it
on the other hand a lot of people
have would like to have a deeper
understanding of not only what are the
forces
and the dictionary or or geography or
genea
geology of the what are the particle
names or whatnot but why why do we have
so many few of them why do we have
why don't we have more exotic situations
and so on so that's that's the question
now i will give you a parallel question
within string theory for which we now
have an answer
so you start with asking okay the
situation we live in
this with all the particles and all that
is very complicated it's very messy can
i idealize it
and the answer is yes you can idealize
it idealize you still can be in four
dimensions
you can be almost in flat space like the
universe we live in like minkowski space
but let's add some ingredient which is
not in our universe
and that ingredient is super symmetry
suppose i say i have
a maximal amount of supersymmetry to
simplify my task
subject to only the assumption that i
have some gauge forces around so what is
the maximum amount of supersymmetry i
can have
which gives me gauge forces like gluons
and so on that's what's called n equals
to four
supersymmetric theories in four
dimensions fine so you restrict your
attention to that
then you ask within this class do i have
any reason
that the number of blue ones are finite
now if you don't include gravity in the
discussion
it turns out you have no bounds you can
perfectly understand these theories
and you can have artificially large
number of gluons in that theory
however if you include the gravity it
turns out
that the group choices are finite you
cannot
have our pretty big group so it turns
out
the rank of the group should be less
than or equal to 22.
so out of an infinite number of
possibilities somehow just
including gravity questions involving
consistency of gravity
mixing with the rest fixes what are the
particle spectrum
in that theory and what are the possible
forces and so on so that means the
question of gravity in that context
shows us crucial to answering these
questions
so now you say well we don't live in
supersymmetrics theory so why do i care
about this
this proves the concept that gravity can
restrict
what are the possible content of the
forces that we see around us
of course we hope to extend these kind
of arguments to the universes like ours
which have less supersymmetry or no
supersymmetry
and that's but that proof of concept is
what motivates us
that yes perhaps the answer is good toy
model
is a cherished approach in physics we
always start with saying
let's study the harmonic oscillator of
this or that that's a toy model the
harmonic acid that really doesn't exist
the idealized one is only idealized
thought but we always do it that's
physics the physics precisely modeling
so string theory is at the worst case a
model of what our universe could look
like
and so at the very very rudimentary form
is that you want to say okay a structure
which is
like string theory how could it
potentially give a universe
like our universe and so that kind of
juxtaposition is very similar
to the well-honored tradition of
harmonic oscillator
as toy models of certain physics concept
we want to understand
is there anything any observation or
lack of observation that would cause you
to abandon
string theory well i think that
abandoning is
a strong word for it for me i think for
me there is
by now there's no stops if you give me a
theoretical substitute for string theory
which is better in some way
and has explained at least as much as
string theory has done then i will
abandon it
but i like nothing nothing like this is
in the cards i think
uh we are if we understand that there
are some obvious predictions of string
theory which are
ruled out in some form then we go by i
will go back and
search my on my understanding of string
theory and perhaps we
we made the mistakes along with our
understanding because i think
part of an issue is that we don't have a
complete formulation of what string
theory is so
we are kind of on a difficult uh
platform to be that sure is string carry
right because string theory false
to do that you have to know exactly what
string there is and we don't know that
yet
so i would go back and check my
understanding of the subject
and uh correspondingly what about super
symmetry where would you say we are
in terms of your credulity or prior
bayesian prior on that
uh veracity of supersymmetry well i see
that my problem
right now is the supersymmetry is not
there in anywhere near our energy scales
in large hadron collider
but i would say that there is my high
prior with the sufficiently high energy
could be all the way to clank energies
you might restore some super symmetry so
i think
that supersymmetry is in some sense a
good player but i wouldn't say that
that's a necessary ingredient for string
fear
we do have models in string theory where
no super smash arises
so some people some of my colleagues i
don't know why they kind of say super
symmetry is a prediction of string
theory i wouldn't go that far
there are models within string theory
which are perfectly fine and have no
supersymmetry
i want to read the passage from the book
towards the end about gauge symmetry you
see many important properties of
particle
physics involve what are called gauge
symmetries these involve somewhat
different flavor the more familiar
symmetries we see all around us
with regard to translational symmetry
you might say an experiment performed
and the two different points should have
the same result
with regard to gauge symmetry we might
say that these two different points are
essentially the same point
what does that mean and how do
physicists
use gauge theory or symmetry as sort of
a hack
to solve puzzles
right so uh
so so first of all what is gauge
symmetry gate symmetry is a symmetry
that you kind of want to delete
in a sense it's a very strange symmetry
so let me explain what that means
so um so
an example of this discussed in that
same chapter that you mentioned in the
book
suppose you have you talk about the
exchange rate let's say between the us
dollar and euro
you have some exchange like you know
whatever one dollar one one euro let's
say is one point two dollars
okay fine suppose the european union
decides tomorrow to
to change the to change the units of
their money
and the what used to be one euro now
becomes 100 euros
okay then the exchange rate between the
u.s dollar and the euro will change
by a factor of 100. that's what we call
gate symmetry
we will say in this context there's a
symmetry which shows that rate has to
get multiplied by a factor of 100 or
divided by a factor of 100 appropriately
is it a deep fact well it's just the
renaming of what you mean by your unit
that's all
so gate symmetry is like that so it's a
redundancy of a definition it's not like
it's not a fundamental number there it's
just if you change your units
that number changes that's all and so so
gate symmetry is is
akin to that statement now why that
should come up with so much power in
terms of applicability in our universe
is that obvious why should our universe
be made of gauge forces
and so forth why should we really be
dealing with forces
in that form and this that that requires
a further thought and that turns out to
be
the basic statement is the following is
that if you look at
uni property called unitarity which is
needed for consistency of a quantum
theory
which basically means the probability of
something happening is one
it turns out that the spin of light
particles is less than or equal to two
and so if you look at the bosons would
spin less than or equal to two they're
only three choices
two one and zero and spin two is
graviton
and spin zero is like higgs particle and
spin one
is like a gauge particle so the
existence of the asymmetry is needed to
make spin one
theory work so you cannot describe a
spin one particle without this
redundancy so
just from this picture we are forced to
have this redundancy so i would say that
the notion is to trying to make sense of
a particle which has a spin one
forces us to consider gate symmetry
and i was thinking about that in the
context i also talked about that
particular problem uh with juan now the
same
and he uh he referred me also of course
to the original
some of the original work was uh by p.m
milani and eric weinstein on that a
particular example deriving
uh maxwell's equations from it i was
wondering you know it's not so often
i'll get a chance to run a crazy idea by
someone as eminent as you uh cameron but
could could we not also use an example
from language
in other words as as shakespeare said a
rose by any other name would smell as
sweet is that another example
of a gauge transformation and so is
there anything we could do with it
i don't know if you're saying engaging
you i think i i think that the main
thing is
not that mention of that symmetry but
that that idea is needed for spin one to
make sense spin
one particles to make sense spin one
masses particles to make sense need that
now why need that we can understand we
can explain it in the context of
particle physics but
by itself a redundancy and a name should
not be that important and in some sense
gate symmetry is encoding redundancy
yeah i had a conversation with noam
chomsky about that as well
you know kind of what we call something
and in the words of
richard feynman who would say you know
just because you know the name of
something doesn't mean you know
that thing and i want to get to feynman
in just a little bit
um so uh one of the other delightful
things about this book
and we're talking with professor kimran
rafa harvard university
about his wonderful new book puzzles to
unlock uh to unravel the universe
which is uh just quite spectacular um
is is this notion that um that there are
sort of hacks and tricks that we can use
to
to unravel certain puzzles but that some
puzzles by their nature
um you know have have this mysterious
quality to them
and and one thing that you spend a lot
of time on which i'm very fascinated by
is is god and religion and i'm i'm a
practicing
a jew myself and i always say i don't
know if i believe in
in god but i believe in religion i i
think there are things that we can that
religion can do and it's practiced
uh properly that can benefit a person's
life the
uh the absence of working one day a week
uh is a very big thing in my life and it
contributes to my sanity the sabbath
every day every week i don't work i
don't send emails i don't tweet i don't
text
you know those are that's kind of a
commitment to a religion
if not a god i want to say ask you a few
questions about that some of the
greatest minds in history
were religious believers isaac newton
you mentioned in the book
um you don't mention this aspect of him
but his his biggest
accomplishment according to him this is
a man who came up the principia invented
calculus
uh the universal law of universal
gravitation he said
his uh biggest accomplishment was being
christ-like in other words that he
he never married he never had
relationships with women in that way and
that way he dedicated his life to
pursuit of knowledge of course he also
practiced alchemy and did other things
but
um what can you say about the role of
religion in
in your life in this book
what does it mean to you and and
obviously you don't proselytize it all
but you seek a harmonio
harmonization a conciliance between
uh between religion and and god it
reminds me of your former late great
colleague there stephen j gould what can
you say about the role of religion
in your life and maybe even as a
physicist if that's applicable
well i i did not talk about the role of
religion in my life i try to keep it out
of the
public view i keep that completely
private so i would not discuss that
aspect but i would
instead say that religion and science
are
neither contradictory nor reinforcing
each other in my view there are two
separate domains of thoughts
or beliefs and i just in that in the in
that chapter
in that book i try to explain why i felt
that
trying to prove or disprove the
existence of god the religion and so on
is a futile task in the context of
science
and i try to also try to
also say also the opposite that if if
scientists feel that they can disprove
or say that religion is useless i also
discounted that too by
giving counter examples including the la
mata understanding of
the proposal that the universe may have
come from the beginning of
of of some primordial existence which
something einstein refused
to accept and called i do not know if
it's hot through the statement is but
uh mythology is uh christianity
christian mythology i'm not sure if that
is
what actually happened but the main
point is that being motivated by
religion
is not a necessarily a bad idea as an
example sure newton is another example
on the other hand uh you know some
people do great without religion people
like hawking and so on were perfectly
fine with
doing exploring their ideas completely
free of any such assumptions and
they did great work too so i i don't try
to
i don't try to make a statement really
about what it should or shouldn't be and
my views i don't i came to myself
because i didn't feel
i have anything to offer in terms of
advice or anything to anybody so i just
said there's no point me
sharing what i feel should be or
shouldn't be but i think
listening to other scientists that who
have felt strongly about it one way or
the other
and seeing okay what does it tell us
about the role of science for their life
and for religion and science how they
mix in their lives was useful perhaps
but then i also thought that it would
fit with my book because
you know it's a serious discussion
there's science and religion and
the book i'm talking about puzzles
sounds like a very you know
you know fun kind of thing is a little
bit less less less serious so
trying to bring those two subjects a
very serious subject with the very
casual topic
puzzles i thought it'd be an interesting
combination i was trying to bring
puzzles to to lighten up the mood so to
speak that okay
there are these serious discussions but
let's talk about puzzles in this context
and i
offered a few puzzles some of my
favorite puzzles are actually in that
chapter so
so i think uh i just use it as a
springboard for discussions really i
didn't want to offer anything specific
but i think i think the main thing i
wanted to convey in that thing is we
should be tolerant
of viewpoints and that was that was the
that was basically i was driving in that
chat
yeah we hear a lot about the hostility
of science to religion i always point
out that
the word torah which is a hebrew word
for the bible the old testament
it doesn't mean knowledge which is what
the word science means in greek science
and
or latin rather means knowledge and
torah means wisdom
and teaching it so there really are as
your late great colleague steven j gould
would say
non-overlapping magisteria they don't
necessarily
have to interfere with each other i
always also point out that in the book
of genesis at least
again i'm not proselytizing again i i
consider myself a devout agnostic
uh which is which is something i think i
have in common with uh the late great
freeman j dyson who's a friend of mine
and a friend of my shows
man many times did he appear on it he
used to say well
the existence or lack thereof of god is
a great mystery and
scientists love mysteries and we love
puzzles and maybe you can solve it maybe
it's a mystery or maybe it's a puzzle
we don't know but to give permission as
you do
um to at least consider it and and have
an eminent
scientist uh such as yourself you know
it's one thing if i
if i try to defend religion uh but
someone of your stature defends
right yeah well i'm just saying it's
delightful to have uh
that you don't you're not scared of it
and that you
are quite um are quite comfortable but
again
you're not proselytized this book is not
a book about uh
you know why you should believe in a
particular religion uh whatsoever so i i
just want to commend you on that i found
it so refreshing and delightful
i want to talk uh just in the last few
minutes i know you're uh super busy
today
uh but there are um many mysteries that
i think
are in the in the theoretical physics
world there's a particular researcher
who's a friend of mine a friend of the
show her name is sabine hassenfelder
she's in germany as a research scientist
and she made a video last week
uh kind of criticizing lenny suskin and
others and even hawking
uh with the black hole information
paradox claiming
that in her words and she's had nothing
much good to say about physics
theoretical physics is progress in the
last 40 years according to her it's been
stagnant
but anyway she criticizes the black hole
information paradox
as um as the biggest overhyped
uh bit of of physics that's ever come
along
i i think that's a little bit over the
top but her point is that
these uh the laws and so forth that
govern this are completely
um you know kind of more or less
pedestrian and furthermore
they can't be solved because we don't
know if hawking radiation exists
and and we can never measure it so a lot
of these things even from a pragmatist
point of view
are some are somewhat pointless maybe
this is relevant to what we talked about
earlier
if so we don't really have to dwell on
it but um
why do you think that there is so much
attention to things like
um uh like like black hole uh
information or the multiverse which
we'll
maybe close out the scientific portion
of the podcast with
why is there so much interest in that
world and the double slit experiment epr
and all these things
why does the public get so wrapped up in
this and do physicists
maybe do a disservice by by
over hyping things like this
well before i get to this i think people
who talk about subjects like black hole
and so on especially criticizing or
whatever
from outside they could do that
perhaps if they had a scientific
standing
and by that i mean not just to say well
i have read physics i've got my phd in
physics therefore i can say whatever i
want
i think if you have not done sufficient
research yourself in some direction to
try to criticize somebody else i think
is a little bit of suspect
so that's some of the comments so it's
like throwing a stone
stone at a building or glass or
classroom with glass things
because you're not inside and so that to
me is a bit of a childish reaction
as far as more seriously okay so what it
is why is it that we think is an
exciting subject and so on
well it's exciting because because it
was a mystery
it's still to some extent deliver
mystery and
mysteries always guide new physics and
so
for us that's the reason we study black
hole of course black hole sounds you
know
captures one's imagination what if you
fall in it you know why is what if a
black hole is near us and this and that
so it can easily captivate public but
that's not necessarily the reason we are
talking about it
the reason we are talking about is that
many of the mysteries of
fundamental physics seems to be wrapped
up in it
and that to us that aspect to us is what
is fascinating and yes of course it will
it will be interesting when you want to
describe what we are doing to general
public to explain that link
because the general public can hold on
to that concept that's being interesting
because they can feel it oh black oh
that's fun
that's cool that's strange that's exotic
let's see what we have to say about it
so so to say that we are we are excited
about it
is not because we want to kind of
get the public going with the excitement
we are excited about it because i think
many of our deep questions are related
enigma of black holes and a lot of them
can be reformulated as properties of
black hole
you lose information if you throw
something into the black hole can you
figure out later on what was it that you
threw in
or after the black hole evaporates
there's zero information
that's the information loss in other
words understanding that process tells
you
the meaning of fundamental meaning of
whether or not the theory
can or cannot lose information black
hole is a way to
ask that question and that turned out to
be deeply related to many other aspects
of the theory
so for us it is that aspect now
to undermine it to say no it doesn't
radiate or does it radiate we cannot
measure it therefore it's a bad question
and all that
is again the kind of things that it
sounds like this parallax that you
mentioned this
experiment that later on was able we
were able to do but right now we cannot
do
was that oh yeah are the stars really
you know far away or infinitely far away
what is it
what what is the connection with with
with why don't they seem to move and
they indeed move it just have no enough
not enough accuracy
same with black hole if you try to say
at that time thinking about them at
finite distance and
has a meaning is would have sounded
crazy during the greek time perhaps
some people but we now know that's not
the right way of asking of course
the people who said that that's a bad
question to ask because you cannot
resolve it
would have won in the short term because
yes in the short term you cannot measure
it the parallax was not possible to
measure
because was it a bad thing to raise no
it wasn't a bad thing to raise and
so we have learned that through history
what we should pay attention to and
i think that uh people who throw stones
rather than alternatives are never the
ones who create the new science and so
there's one thing to have a constructive
christian of a theory
to say oh you know what your theory
typically wants to have let's say five
dimensions why not four okay let's try
to find the model y
four dimensional space time arises and
so on that's a good question and we are
not saying we have understood that
but to say oh no this is bad this is bad
and so forth without any given
alternative i think it's just
disservice to science and i to be
frankly frankly it's just
i think to try to uh get publicity
in the sake of for the sake of publicity
to try to say something and
to me controversial statement just to
attract attention i think is unfortunate
yeah i mean to be fair to her she does
say that she's written papers about the
subject herself but yeah she's
yeah certainly takes takes out a lot of
uh aggression
uh but you know i think it's important
to hear the voices
as long as you say they're acting
towards a
um maybe not necessarily conciliatory
you know perspective but a congenial
perspective they're trying to do
something constructive i i agree with
that
i want to uh conclude the scientific
portion just asking uh along the lines
i talked with shelly glacial last week
and he has a wonderful book
called interactions written in 1988 and
in that book towards the end he has a
series of
of questions for the future that he
suspected would be answered in the super
conducting super collider
and and other things uh of course that
wasn't to be
uh but the the question of uh something
like the higgs he he just assumed that
we would understand the mass no the mass
of the higgs not too distant future
yes we didn't learn it from the
superconducting super collider but we
found it out eventually
uh and uh but he goes through other
other questions which in my mind are
much deeper
and it was quite a treat and a delight
for me to go over this scorecard with
him and
have have this eminent uh you know
harvard professor of boston university
give a score you know f f f you know
because some of the things that he
listed on there
aside from you know our neutrinos mass
list which we now know
yeah which we didn't know back then that
they're not mass this at least one of
them is not massless maybe two are not
massless rather
um but nevertheless why are there three
you know generations of
of quarks why are there um so many
fundamental parameters why are there so
many particles
um what is the uh you know fundamental
dimensions of space
time those things we we haven't really
learned much about
and i'm not going to ask you to comment
on those uh there was one or two as i
said the higgs
wasn't even mentioned but the neutrino
mass being
non-zero was uh the protons lifetime
uh he thought you know at that time is
like 10 of the 28th years now we think
it's much bigger maybe a thousand times
longer
uh and that had some implications for
super symmetry i want to ask you
your score card what would you give uh
our understanding of things like
the multiverse uh the string landscape
what kind of grades would you give to
such subjects currently
and then what kinds of things would you
want when the next edition of
of puzzles comes out hopefully in 30
years after becoming an international
bestseller
thank you i think that uh the scorecard
the the score you give to something is
based on whether or not good attempts
have been made and how much progress has
been made
compared to the difficulties ahead so
when you measure it against how much
complication is on the way
i would give it a plus if you ask me
if the scorecard is to try to measure
how close we are to finally settling it
i'll get it f
or very close to f so it depends on what
is what is the scorecard for
so we are very far unfortunately still
from making a prediction which is
really precise and quantitative and we
can say this is a definite prediction of
string theory is that
it's either this or the whole thing
falls apart and it's very precise we are
not there yet by far
so so it depends on that i would say
that as far as the scorecard i would
give a
i would view it as what is possible to
do in terms of theoretical and huge
huge things have been there i think to
underestimate
the dualities that meaning of the
dualities that we have learned
it's it's remarkable how much we have
learned for example you mentioned this
question that shelley raised we know the
fundamental dimension of space-time
we have learned something about this we
have learned that's a bad question
why is it a bad question we have learned
that that counts that question
depends on which viewpoint you have
there is no fundamental answer to that
question
it depends on which parameter regions
you look at
so the dimension is not a fundamental
concept that even that realization
that you cannot settle that that that
question is a bad question
it's only in one corner you can say it's
this in a different corner is a
different number so it's not an invalid
concept
those are progress so for us we have
made progress in that form
so conceptual progress is is is what i
would say
certainly has happened holography is
another amazing conceptual progress
duality is
more generally is and so i think we are
learning quite a bit
i think the progress is going to be not
super fast
if we are measuring it against the
yardstick of connecting to experiments
but if in terms of what new things we
have learned is huge we have learned a
huge amount
and it continues to unravel very good
uh cameron thank you i'm gonna if you
have just a few more minutes i would
like to ask you some questions i ask all
of my guests on the show
is that okay sure okay great
so the first one in uh in judaism in the
hebrew
language there's a concept of what's
called an ethical will
and that differs from a material will in
that it
is not bequeathing monetary or material
objects
to your offspring but instead is
bequeathing wisdom
and and and discoveries that you've made
outside the material world
and it's meant to benefit not only your
biological children
one of whom put me in touch with you so
i want to thank that particular
vapha son uh for putting me in touch
through the magical medium of twitter
just beyond my son yes yes so thank him
very much and when this comes out we'll
send it to him to share
but i want to ask you not only for for
him and his brothers but but for the
whole world
what would you put in an ethical will a
will of wisdom
not only for your biological children
but for your ideological children of
which i count myself as one
thank you it's a great question um
i would say the following uh
and i was prefaced by saying where this
wisdom may come from
it's from the realization of the
importance of duality in physics
and what we have learned and i think
this is a broader application
is that the best viewpoint about the
subject depends on the question being
asked
there is no best viewpoint and that best
viewpoint
is subject to the question so that also
opens up our mind to be open-minded
that we should not say this is the way
to look at it
everything else is bad and so on and so
forth we have learned that contradictory
sounding views
are sometimes necessary to understand
the subject contradictory sounding views
which are nevertheless consistent
but in a subtle way turning out to be
the beautiful aspects that dualities
have
have shown can happen and so in my
opinion
openness and the fact that duality shows
us that multitude of attitudes and views
is important to appreciate and connect
not only in a scientific context but
in a broader human societal aspect i
think is a good could have a good
applications
very nice so i don't know if you're a
science fiction fan but
shelley is a huge science fiction fan
and i asked him
about arthur c clarke who is the
namesake of the center that i act as a
co-director
and he had he had written the
the book on which the movie 2001 a space
odyssey is based so
have you seen that movie or are you like
fc
you have seen it yes good so you might
remember in that
in that movie in the opening scene there
are these primates in africa and they
discover
this obelisk this monolith this black
ominous structure
that's placed there and then later they
don't know what to do with it they hit
it with a bone or something
and then later you see it's on the moon
and astronauts are encountering it you
know they've obviously developed i want
to ask you
um and it's sort of meant as a as a time
capsule meant to be discovered when
humanity is ready for this knowledge
i wonder if you knew you could make a
billion-year-long lasting time capsule
what would you put on it or in it what
would it what would it
encapsulate
[Music]
well um i think billion years down the
line what i would think now is probably
going to be irrelevant and so
one of the things i believe in is our
knowledge is continually evolving and
almost none of the things that we think
are correct now is going to stand up to
be exactly correct
they're going to be good approximations
they're going to be modifications and so
on so
to try to put something so solid for
future i would feel hesitant for the for
for that reason
if nothing else however if you want to
brag about something we have learned in
our society in science
you know we can put some aspects of i
don't know this and that theory
to show that yeah we have a string for
example we have understood this much
of course hundred thousand ten thousand
years down the line they might laugh at
us
okay they understood something not too
much but okay just like the way
we look at what you know scientists were
doing three thousand years ago
we don't we don't think they were really
you know at the cutting edge of things
now we kind of say okay that was fun
they were smart people but maybe not for
answering this and this and that so
i'll be hesitant to put my word of
wisdom in any form to for the future
generation i hope that
they would not laugh too hard at us
that's well although to
at least two ancient greeks actually
three ancient greeks plato
uh archimedes and aristarchus make
very prominent appearances in your
delightful book yeah i
this it's just what you said reminds me
of what richard fineman said about he
i didn't get to ask him this question
but he said if in some cataclysm
all scientific knowledge were to be
destroyed and only one sentence passed
on to the next generation of creatures
what statement would contain the most
information in the fewest words
i believe it is the atomic hypothesis
that all things are made of atoms little
particles that move around in perpetual
motion
attracting each other when they are a
little distance apart but repelling
barely
being squeezed onto one another in that
sentence you'll see an enormous amount
of information about the world
if just a little imagination and
thinking are applied and of course this
is the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
so i've managed to unify feynman plato
aristarchus
aristotle and the great cameron vapha
who would go down what
sentence to that maybe what's that i
would add maybe one little footnote to
that sentence go for it atoms and
extended objects like strings
ah okay okay that's bold
yeah as yogi berra said the great uh
prognosticator said it's difficult to
make predictions
especially about the future okay the
last sentence
uh the last question i ask all my guests
come on is
uh relates to arthur c clarke as well he
had these famous three laws one of which
was any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic he had
another saying
called his second law which was that for
every expert there's an
equal and opposite expert and then his
third law says
the only way of discovering the limits
of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible and that's the
origin of the name of my podcast
i want to ask you what advice would you
give to a young
kamran baffa what what things seemed
impossible when you were a young person
but now because you had courage and you
went into the impossible now seems
doable to you and on if only in
hindsight
well to me math was always always
attractive the ideas of math hanging
together
the beautiful beauty of euclidean
geometry understanding the relation of
simple objects
and i also was always fascinated by you
know things around us like
you know how the how does the whole
thing work what why there are atoms how
does this
work and that work and this one and
these two things sounded to me
like separate universes like math
euclidean geometry and so on
is there and then you have this real
world that's around us there's nothing a
priority to do this map
to try to bring these two universes
together or closer
first of all i noticed not only that
there are already big links between them
through
centuries of work when i got to learn
more but then i felt could they become
even closer and in fact indispensable
for one another
and so when in the context of string
theory the two have come together in
such a way that you cannot do one
without the other you cannot do physics
without math
and now also you cannot do math without
physics
so the fact that these things can be
combined is something that
is really pleasurable for me in terms of
my own interests but
i think anybody has their own interests
and i hope that they don't
they everybody follows what they are
deeply passionate about and
you know there are things which are
fashionable today or may not be
fashionable tomorrow and so forth but
whatever you're excited by if you follow
it regardless of
being fashionable or not fashionable
gives you pleasure and usually
by that action you're thinking deeply
about it you will
convey something important to the rest
so i think follow your dreams is
is a cliche but i think is the correct
cliche in this case yes and as you say
in the
beginning of the book you dedicate it to
your parents
um as well as your family uh simeon and
javad for nurturing your curiosity
and i think that's so uh delightful that
you uh have now shared this curious
uh investigator uh perspective that you
bring
uniquely you're a towering figure in
science and
and i really appreciate your time i have
to go now to paint uh
the surface of gabriel's horn it's going
to keep me busy right
yes it will a very very long time maybe
quickly time but
it's a pleasure brian to talk with you
and the very
enjoyable discussion and questions thank
you for having me on your practice
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
[Music]
magic
[Music]
you